The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: This is our
first introductory meeting
of the course, which is 9.04.
And we are going to cover vision
and audition in this course,
and there are going to
be two of us lecturing.
My name is Peter Schiller,
and this is Chris Brown.
And I will be talking
about the vision portion,
and Chris will be lecturing
about the auditory portion.
Now, what I'm going
to do is I'm going
to hand out the syllabi
that we have, in this case,
for the first half
of the course.
And that we are going to
discuss in some detail
today for the first
half of the lecture,
and Chris is going to discuss
it for the second half.
So that is the basic
plan for today.
And I will go through some of
the basic procedures and issues
that we may want to deal with at
this very introductory portion.
So first of all, let me talk
about the reading assignments.
If you have the handout,
they are ready for you.
If you look at the
second page, that's
where we have the assigned
readings for the vision
half of the course.
Now, for that half
of the course,
the top eight assignments
are all articles
in various journals.
We don't have a textbook for
this portion of the course.
And then in addition to
the assigned readings,
we have recommended readings
that are listed there.
And then another
important factor
that is listed
there-- let me first
say that the lectures will be
put on Stellar, in most cases,
after each lecture.
And in addition, the videos
that we are now recording
will also become available,
but they will not
be available until well
after each lecture.
So I would advise each of
you to come to the lectures
rather than hoping to read
the assigned material only
or to eventually
look at the videos.
The reason I'm
telling you this is
that our analysis has shown
that those students who
attend the lectures
regularly get
much better grades on the exams
than the students who do not.
So I strongly will
urge all of you
to come to as many lectures
as you possibly can.
Now, the additional
requirement that you're
going to have for this course is
to write two research reports,
one for vision and
one for audition.
And the assigned written report
that you need to put together
is in a paper at the
bottom of the second page.
In this case, it's
going to be a paper that
was written quite
some years ago,
a very important and remarkable
paper that has been published
by Oster and Barlow,
as you can see.
And the task for you will
be to not just report
what they had reported,
because that's repetitious,
but to do a bit of
research and write
about what has been discovered
since the remarkable findings
that these two people
had made at the time.
All right.
So that's the research report.
And then I want to
specify the exams.
We are going to
have a midterm exam,
and the exact date for this has
already been set on October 23.
All right?
But as I say, you
can find this, and I
will specify that in more
detail in just a minute.
And then we are going
to have a final exam
at the end of the term.
The exact date for
this, as always at MIT,
will not have been set until
probably sometime in November.
So now let me also specify
the grade breakdown.
I think that's
important for all of us.
The written report for
each half of the course--
there's going to be one
report, as I've already said,
for vision and
one for audition--
and that will constitute
10% of the grade for each.
And the midterm exam,
this constitutes 25%.
The final exam constitutes
55% of the overall grade.
And in that, 15% will be on
vision and 40% on audition.
So if you add that up, you can
see that vision and audition
are set up to be exactly
equally weighed for the exams.
MICHELLE: Hi.
I'm Michelle.
I'll be helping the professors,
especially with [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So I'm Chris Brown,
and I'm one of the instructors.
I'll be teaching
the second half.
And my research is on two areas,
brain stem auditory reflexes,
like the startle reflex and
the middle ear muscle reflex.
And I also work on animal models
of the auditory brain stem
implant, which is a
neural prosthesis that's
used in deaf individuals.
PROFESSOR: All right.
And I'm Peter Schiller, and
I work on the visual system.
And I'm a professor
here in our department.
So that's very nice.
Thank you for the introductions.
And I hope, you guys, we
all get to know each other.
I'm very impressed that
there's so many seniors here.
That's actually unusual.
I don't remember having
this high a percentage
of seniors in the class.
That's really very
nice, very nice.
OK.
So now we are going to
talk, for the first part
of today's lecture, about what
aspects of visual processing
we are trying to
understand and, therefore,
what we are going
to try to cover
in this course in
terms of topics.
OK?
So first of all,
what we are going
to do for several lectures
is to talk about the layout
and organization of the
visual system itself.
Most of it we will discuss as
it applies to higher mammals,
in particular monkeys
and primates and humans.
Then we are going to talk
about specific aspects
of visual processing.
We're going to try to understand
how we adapt in vision,
and, very interestingly,
how we are
able to perceive colors and
process them accurately.
Another fascinating
topic is how we
are capable of analyzing motion.
That's a complex, very
interesting topic,
as is depth perception.
And the reason depth
perception is particularly
interesting is
because, as you know,
the retinal surface
is essentially
a two-dimensional arrangement.
And yet from whatever falls
on these two dimensions
in the left and right
eyes, somehow the brain
needs to convert to be able
to see the third dimension.
And as a result,
several mechanisms
have evolved to
accomplish that, and we
are going to discuss them.
Then, again, another
very complex topic
is how we can recognize objects.
Perhaps the most
complex of those
is our incredible ability
to recognize faces.
And that is
highlighted, of course,
by the fact that if you look
at more simple organisms,
like, I don't know, monkeys,
they all look the same to you.
But human beings,
who are actually
more similar to each other
than perhaps monkeys are,
we are really capable
of telling them
apart and readily recognize
them over long periods of time.
So it's a very
interesting topic.
And yet another topic
that we will discuss
is how we make eye movements.
As you probably know,
or you're aware of,
that we are constantly
moving your eye.
You make saccadic eye movements
about three times a second,
thousands of times a day,
hundreds of thousands of times,
to be able to see things
clearly in the world.
So we are going to
try to understand
how that incredible
ability has evolved
and how it is
realized by the brain.
OK.
So now to look at exactly how
we are going to cover this,
let me go through this.
During the next lecture,
which is September 9,
we are going to look at the
basic layout of the retina
and the lateral
geniculate system,
as well as how the visual
system in general is wired.
Then on September
11, we're going
to look at the
visual cortex, then
at the ON and OFF
channels, so-called,
that you'll realize what they
are once we talk about it.
And then there's
another set of channels
that originates in
the retina, which
are the midget and
parasol channels.
We'll discuss those, try to
figure out why did they evolve
and what is their role
in being able to see
the world in realistic fashion.
Then we're going to talk about
adaption and color, depth
perception, form perception.
And then we're going to have
a lot of fun on October 2,
and we're going to look
at illusions and also
visual prosthesis,
because one of you,
in particular, is
interested in that topic.
Then we are going to talk about
the neural control of visually
guided eye movements.
That's going to consist
of two sessions.
And then we're going to
talk about motion perception
and another aspect
of eye movements
when we pursue something
with smooth eye movements.
And then we're going
to have an overview.
And then, lastly,
on October 23rd,
we are going to have
the midterm exam.
That's going to cover questions
from all of these lectures.
I should tell you right now
that the midterm exam is going
to consist of
multiple-choice questions.
So you're not going to, maybe,
asked to write anything.
You're going to
have to just pick
from each of the questions
the correct answer.
All right.
So now what I would like to talk
about next in a summary fashion
are what we call the
tools of the trade.
What has happened
over the many years
that scientists
tried to understand
how the visual system and, for
that matter the brain, works,
what kinds of methods
have been employed.
And so I'm going to talk about
each of these just very briefly
this time, and then they
will come up repeatedly
during all of the lectures.
Now, the first method
I'm going to talk about
is called psychophysics.
I'm sure most of you
know what that is.
It's a scientific way to study
behavior of humans and animals
to determine how
well they can see.
Now, there are several
procedures with this.
I'm going to describe
one that's used
both in humans and monkeys.
And what you can do nowadays,
you can use a color monitor,
and I will describe
that in just a second.
After that, I will
talk about anatomy.
I will talk about
electrophysiology,
pharmacology, brain lesions,
imaging, and optogenetics.
So now let's start with
psychophysics in more detail.
So here is a color monitor,
and either monkeys or humans
can be trained to first
look at a fixation spot.
And that's important
because we want to always
be able to present
stimuli in selected
locations of the visual
field or selected
locations along the retina.
This is particularly
important, because when
you study the brain, different
regions of the visual field
representation are located
in different areas,
for example, in
the visual cortex.
So what you do then is you
can present a single stimulus
like this, and the task
of the human or the monkey
is to either make a
saccadic eye movement to it,
say that's where
it is, or to press
a lever that's in front of them.
And then on each trial,
it appears someplace else.
You can present it in
many different locations,
and maybe one of
those locations will
be relevant to what part of
the brain you are studying.
And then what you do,
you can systematically
vary all kinds of
aspects of the stimulus.
You can vary the color.
You can vary the contrast.
You can vary the size.
You can vary the shape.
And by systematically
varying this,
you can create curves to
describe exactly how well you
can see any
particular thing like,
for example, just
how much contrast you
need to perceive something.
All right.
So that's called
the detection task.
Now, a related task, which has
also been used extensively,
is called the
discrimination task.
In this case, you present
a fixation spot again.
The person or the
monkey fixates,
and then you present a whole
bunch of stimuli, one of which
is different from the others.
And you have to select
where that one had appeared,
the one that's different,
by making an eye movement
or pressing the
appropriate lever.
Now, when you do this,
you systematically
can vary the difference between
the so-called distractor
stimuli, which
are all identical,
and the target
until the person is
no longer able to
tell the difference.
And that way you can,
again, generate a curve.
And you can specify just what
is the amount of difference
that you need to
put in this, say,
how good are you at perceiving
slightly different colors.
All right?
And by doing that
systematically,
you can generate
these functions using
these psychophysical
procedures to determine
pretty well how
you're able to see.
And now this particular
approach is also very useful
when it comes to studying
individuals, humans
in this case, who have
some problems with vision.
So if they have a
problem in seeing colors,
you can readily
determine, well, what's
the magnitude of that problem?
And thereby it can tell
you what procedures
might be used to try to
ameliorate their shortcoming.
Now, another method that
has been used extensively
in not only vision, but in
many, many different areas
of studying the brain, including
audition of course, is anatomy.
Numerous methods have evolved
in the course of anatomists
working on these problems, and
the first is a very simple one.
You just look at
the whole brain.
And I'm showing this because
this is a monkey brain,
and you will encounter the
monkey brain repeatedly.
And it so happens
that after people
have studied this
extensively, they
were able to give
names to just about
every gyrus or every brain
area and also relate it
to what the function
is of those areas.
And so, for example, just
to name a few of these,
this is called the
central sulcus.
I need to do one
more thing here.
OK.
So this here is
the central sulcus.
All right?
Just for you to
remember, humans also
have a central
sulcus, of course.
And this is the lunate sulcus.
And this region back here--
let's see, did I label this?
Oh, here's a couple more, the
arcuate and the principalis.
You will encounter
these repeatedly.
And this region
back here is the one
which is the primary visual
cortex in monkeys that
has been extensively
studied and has
yielded remarkable discoveries
about the way it works.
So that is called area V1,
or primary visual cortex.
All right.
So now just another
example, if I
can show you just a few
examples of anatomy.
Here's another example showing
what the eye looks like.
And the remarkable thing
about the human eye,
and the eye of monkeys
as well and primates,
is it has become
highly specialized.
There's a region here
which is called the fovea.
And in that region, you have a
very, very dense distribution
of photoreceptors and
other cells in the retina.
And because of that, you
have very high acuity there.
Now, because of that,
the eye movements
have to become effective for you
to be able to see fine detail.
So even, for example,
when you read,
what do you do when you read?
You make saccadic eye
movements across a line.
Then you go down the next line
three or four saccadic eye
movements, and so
on down the page.
And you do that because you
cannot make out the details
of letters in the
periphery because, there,
the distribution of the
photoreceptors and the cells
in the retina in general
become less and less dense.
So that is a high
degree of specialization
that we will discuss in
much more detail next time.
Now then, all the fibers
from the retinal ganglion
cells course across the
inner surface of the retina
and go to the so-called
optic nerve through which
over a million fibers
from the retina project
into the nervous system.
And how they project
exactly, what that's
like I will discuss
in considerable detail
the next time.
Now, this area here
is often also called
the blind spot,
and that you don't
see even if you close one eye.
But if you do a
careful experiment--
I'll explain that the next
time-- you can actually map out
this little region where
you don't see anything.
They're in different
locations in the two eyes,
so the two blind
spots do not overlap.
And so, consequently, when
you look with both eyes,
you don't have a,
quote, blind spot.
So that's an example of what
the human retina looks like,
and this has been
studied extensively
using a whole array of
anatomical procedures.
Now, the third anatomical
procedure I want to tell you
is labeling individual cells.
Now, the way this was done,
or still is being done,
is that you slice the brain
into very, very thin sections.
And you put them on
a glass, and then you
can look at them
under a microscope.
Now, here's an example of
a cross-coronal section
of the monkey lateral
geniculate nucleus.
That's one region in the brain
to which the retinal ganglion
cells project.
And it's a beautifully
layered structure,
which I'll describe in
detail the next time.
And these little spots
that you see here
are actual cells, which are
labeled using a so-called Nissl
stain.
Now, another method
used in staining cells
is the famous Golgi stain,
which was discovered, invented,
perhaps, you could say, by
Golgi, for which he received
the Nobel Prize in 1906.
The remarkable quality
of those productions
is that this label-- it's a
silver label-- stains not only
the cell bodies, as the Nissl
stain you have just seen,
but also all the processes, the
dendrites as well as the axons.
So you see a whole
cell as a result
of that staining procedure.
Yet another way
to do this, which
is more sophisticated
nowadays, is
to record intracellularly from
a cell and then inject a label.
This happens to be the so-called
Procion Yellow labeling
substance.
You inject in the eye, and then
you process the tissue again
in thin layers.
And this is an example
of what that looks like.
So this also stains all
the processes of the cell.
And the advantage
here is that you
can study this cell
electrophysiologically
and determine what
it is like, and then
stain it so you can establish
the relationship what
the cell does and what
the cell looks like.
All right.
So now let's turn to the
electrophysiological method,
which is a consequence of this,
logical consequence of it.
Once again, here we
have a monkey brain.
And what you do here, we put
microelectrodes into the brain.
Now, this was a
discovery that was
made around the turn of the
century, little bit after.
Initially,
microelectrodes were made
from very thin tubes of
glass, which were heated
and then pulled so that the tip
became smaller than a micron.
So it was very, very small.
Subsequently, other
methods were developed.
They etched fine pieces a wire
until the tip was very, very
small, and then they corded it.
And they then we were able
to put these electrodes
into the brain and record single
cells just like with glass
pipettes.
So the example here then is
that you take a microelectrode,
put it into the brain,
and then that is connected
to an amplifier
system and a computer.
And when you do that, you can
record from a single cell.
Now, as you well
know, single cells
generate action potentials.
And that is shown here
on an oscilloscope
in a schematic fashion.
And what some
clever people did is
that they decided that an easy
way to process information
about the manner
single cells generated
action potentials is to put
this signal onto a loudspeaker
system.
And so every time a cell fired,
what you would literally hear
is beep, beep, like that.
OK?
And so if you shown a
light on it several times,
it will go like
brrrp, like that.
And the big
advantage of this was
that many cells see only a
tiny portion of the world.
And if you don't
know where it is,
you have to take some
projector or something
and move it around.
And if the receptive
field is here,
you go, brrrp, brrrp,
brrrp, brrrp, like that.
OK?
And so then you can map
it out very accurately.
Instead of having to like with
the oscilloscope, you hear it,
and that enables you to do all
kinds of things, experiments,
and you don't have to
look at the oscilloscope.
But you can perform all
sorts of experiments,
and you can hear the
responses of the cell.
Now, another method
that is used extensively
in electrophysiology is
called electrical stimulation.
It's a similar process.
You take a microelectrode,
for example, you
put it in the brain, and then
you pass electric current.
Typically, that electric current
is passed in such a way as
to mimic action potentials.
So if you are to listen to when
it's activated, again, brrrp,
you hear that.
But this time, instead
of the cell firing,
you are firing the area
there, and that then
can elicit a response, all
right, all kinds of responses.
If you stimulate here, for
example-- remember now,
this is the visual
system in the monkey-- as
has been shown in humans,
electrical stimulation elicits
a percept, a small
spot, a star-like image.
In the auditory system
when you stimulate,
you can hear something.
And if you stimulate
in the areas that
are related to moving your
eyes, then the simulation
causes a saccadic eye movement.
So all those methods
are very, very good
in trying to understand better
the organization of the brain
for, in this case for vision,
and for eye movements.
Now, yet another
method that is used--
several methods I should
say-- is pharmacology.
And when you do
pharmacological experiments,
one procedure is-- and
many different procedures,
I'll just describe
one here-- once again,
you can stick a glass
pipette into the brain,
and then you can inject it.
You can inject it either
with actually a syringe
or using several
other methods, and you
can inject all kinds of agents.
For example, you can inject
a neurotransmitter analog
or a neurotransmitter antagonist
to determine what effects it
has in various parts of
the brain and, in our case,
in the visual system or
the ocular motor system.
Now, yet another method
that has been used
is brain inactivation.
Several procedures are available
to inactivate the brain.
Once again, here's
a monkey brain.
And this region
here that I already
told you a little
bit about because
of naming the gyri there, OK, is
called the frontal eye fields.
This region has something
to do with moving your eyes.
So what you can do if you
want to study and find out
just what does this
area do, one procedure
is to-- again, here is
V1-- is to make a lesion.
Now, sometimes you actually
do that in a monkey.
But sometimes in
some experiments,
humans may have an
accident, some event when
you served in
Vietnam or something,
and a region of
the brain has been
removed by virtue of
a bullet or something.
And that way you
can find out what
is the consequence of
having a lesion like that.
You can study, use a
psychophysical procedure,
as I described to
you, to determine just
what is the consequence
of having lost this area.
This is a huge
region of research.
A great many types of
experiments have been done.
One of the famous individuals
who had done this kind of work
is Hans-Lukas Teuber,
who used to be
the chairman of our department
starting way, way, way
back in 1962.
And his specialty was to study
Second World War veterans who
had sustained various
kinds of brain injuries.
And the basis of
that, studying them
using psychophysical
procedures, to assess what
various areas in the brain, what
kind of functions they have,
what kinds of tasks
do they perform.
Now, yet another method, which
has some major advantages,
is to make reversible
inactivations rather than
permanent ones.
And this you can
do by, for example,
using a method of cooling.
There's a device, the
so-called Peltier device,
that you can put on
top of the brain.
And then electronically, you
can cool the surface that
is in touch with
the brain, and then
you can see what happens
when you cool it.
And then when you
warm it up again,
you can see what happens to
recovery, which, in this case,
in almost all cases
like this, leads
to full recovery and
the same performance
as prior to starting
the cooling.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Can you only use this
method for surface structures
or?
PROFESSOR: No.
They have now developed
methods where you can actually
lower them into the brain.
And they're usually much
finer, and very often they're
sort of a loop type device.
And you can lower that into
the gyri or wherever you like,
and, again, do the
reversible cooling.
Yes.
That's a fairly recently
developed device,
and it works extremely well.
Now, yet another approach
is to inject substances
into the brain that
anesthetize, if you will,
a particular region
after the injection,
but only for a limited time.
And then you can see how
the behavior is affected.
Now, a variant of
that that I referred
to before, of course, is
that you can use agents that
are selective, that don't
inactivate the whole area,
but for example, only affect
excitatory neurotransmitters
or only affect inhibitory ones.
So you can do kinds
of selective things.
And so you can
establish the role
of various neurotransmitters
in the role
they play in
various brain areas.
Now, yet another method
very recently developed,
which has been incredibly
successful, is imaging.
As you probably
all know, you all
know we do have an
MRI facility here
in our department on the
ground floor, and some of you
may even have been
subjects in it.
What that does is
when you put a subject
into this-- the variant
of that is called
fMRI, functional Magnetic
Resonance Imaging.
And so if you put a person
in the magnet and you present
a certain set of
stimuli repeatedly, OK,
or differential ones,
whatever, the brain areas
that are active
performing the analysis
that you ask them
to do light up.
So that method-- here's a
complex picture of that.
This is one that is
in Freiberg, Germany.
This is done with monkeys again.
You have this device and
you put the monkey in there.
You lower the device
on it, and then you
can have the subject
perform trained tasks.
And then you can
analyze the brain
and look at the
nature of activation.
And here's an example
of that, whatever
this task is, doesn't matter.
You can see that
a particular brain
region has been very
heavily activated
as a result of whatever
manipulation they did.
Now, there are lots and
lots and lots of experiments
of this sort, and we will
talk about several of those
as we look at various
aspects of the visual system.
Now, the last method I want to
just mention very, very briefly
is optogenetics.
That's a new method, and we
have actually several people
in our department here
who are using this method.
Now, this particular
method-- let
me explain just very quickly
what this is all about.
Does everybody know
what an opsin is?
OK.
How about if I say rhodopsin?
Most of you will know that.
A rhodopsin is a
set of molecules
that are in the rods
in the photoreceptors,
and they are sensitive to light.
Now, there are all
kinds of variants.
That's why I mentioned opsins
rather than rhodopsins.
And what can be done is
that you can selectivity
place these various substances
into selected types of cells
in the brain.
And then, because these cells
become light sensitive just
like the photoreceptors are,
then when you shine light
onto the area where you had
placed these opsins in cells,
you can drive them.
You can make them respond
by turning the light on.
Now, the amazing
thing about that
is that makes it a
more powerful technique
than electrical stimulation,
that you can set this up
in such a way that, for
example, if you use a rhodopsin
substance that is
sensitive to red light,
it will be excited
by the red light.
But if you have a slightly
different substance that
would be inhibited
by blue light,
then you can see what happens
if you excite those cells,
and then you
inhibit those cells.
So this gives you two
sides to the coin,
whereas electrical stimulation
provides only one side.
So that's a wonderful technique.
And here's sort of a
good example of that.
Here we have
injected-- I shouldn't
say injected-- but
genetically labeled
cells with
channelrhodopsin, so-called.
And when that's done, when
you shine in a blue light,
OK, you excite the cell.
And then instead, if you put
in so-called halorhodopsin, OK,
halorhodopsin, then if
you use yellow light
you inhibit the cells.
So that's a
remarkable technique.
It's just at the very
beginning of things,
so we won't talk too
much about this technique
in studying the
visual system yet.
But I bet you that
in another 10 years
this is going to
be a central topic.
All right.
So to summarize
these techniques,
other than the psychophysics,
just remind you again,
number one, we have
electrical recording
using microelectrodes.
OK?
Then secondly, we have
electrical stimulation.
Thirdly, we have injection
of pharmacological agent.
Then we have methods
to inactivate regions,
either permanently by lesions
or reversibly by cooling
or by injecting
various substances.
And lastly, we have
optogenetics that
enables you to activate
cells or inhibit cells
by shining light onto the brain.
So these are quite a
remarkable set of techniques.
And individuals who want
to become neuroscientists,
they're going to have to
learn to master not maybe
all of these techniques,
but certainly some of them
so that they can carry out
new and original experiments
in determining how
the brain works
and, in our case, of course,
how the visual system works.
So that is, in essence then,
what I wanted to cover.
And now we are going to move
on and have Chris tell you
about his portion
of the course, which
will be taught during the
second half of this semester.
So as I said, next
time we are going
to start talking
about, first of all,
about the wiring of the visual
system, the basic wiring.
And then we're going to talk
about the retina in detail
and a little bit about the
lateral geniculate nucleus.
That's the next lecture.
Please.
AUDIENCE: So for the eigtht
readings, the eight assigned
readings that you
have on here, how
will we know when to read what?
PROFESSOR: Well,
that's a good question.
The sections that have
to do with eye movements
that you can see, that you
don't have to read until we
get to the eye movements,
the latter part.
Initially, when we talk about
the retina, for example,
you definitely want to
read the [INAUDIBLE] paper
and the Schiller paper on
parallel information processing
channels.
Then the ones that have to
do with the Hermann grid
illusion and visual
prosthesis, that you
don't have to cover
until you come
to the section on illusions
and visual prosthesis.
PROFESSOR: OK.
Welcome, everybody.
I'm Chris Brown.
And I just, in the
remaining time,
wanted to give you
a synopsis of what's
going to happen during the
second half of the term.
So I'll be giving the lectures
during the second half
on the topic of
audition, or hearing.
And there's my email,
chris_brown@meei.harvard.edu.
So as you can see
by my email, I'm
associated with Harvard, in
fact, Harvard Medical School.
And I'm in the so-called ENT
department at Harvard Med
School, and that stands
for Ear, Nose, and Throat.
So some of you who are going
to be going to medical school
will certainly do
an ENT rotation,
where you learn about the
various aspects of ENT.
And much of it, of
course, is the subject
of otology, what happens
when people have disorders
of hearing, problems
with their hearing.
And in addition,
many ENT doctors
also operate on people who
have head and neck cancers.
So surgeries of
those two types go
on at my hospital, which is
Massachusetts Eye and Ear
Infirmary.
And that's across
the river in Boston,
and it is, of course, one of the
main teaching hospitals for ENT
as well as ophthalmology.
There's a big
Ophthalmology department
where the ophthalmologists
deal with disorders
of sight and vision.
So I have an
introductory reading,
which is a book chapter
that I wrote, and also
with Joe Santos-Sacchi,
which is actually
now in the fourth
edition of a textbook
called Fundamental Neuroscience.
And I believe this book chapter
is on the course website now.
And it summarizes
pretty much what
I'll cover during the
semester in a reading
that you could probably
do in an hour or less,
and it has many of the
figures that I'll use.
So if you're shopping
around for a course
and want to know what's going to
happen in the second half here,
you can look at
that book chapter.
There's a nice
textbook that I'll also
be assigning a
number of readings
from throughout
the term, and it's
called Auditory Neuroscience,
Making Sense of Sound
by Schnupp, Nelken, and King.
And these fellows are, in the
case of the first and the last,
at Oxford University, and they
work on psychophysics, that is,
how we perceive hearing.
And they test
humans, and they also
do a fair amount of
animals psychophysics.
And in the case
of Israel Nelken,
he's at Hebrew
University in Israel.
And he does a lot of
electrophysiological
recordings-- you heard
about electrophysiology
from Peter's talk just
now-- and recordings
especially from the
auditory cortex.
But this is a very nice
book for coverage especially
of the central auditory
pathway in psychophysics.
And it's pretty cheap.
I think it's $30.
And I believe I was told
earlier that you can get it,
as an MIT student, online free.
And what's good about
the online edition
is there are lots
of demonstrations,
each indicated by the little
icon in the margin of the text.
And when you click on
that demonstration,
if you have your
earbuds in you can
hear what the sound
demonstration is.
And I'll be doing quite a
lot of sound demonstrations
through the course of the
semester because I think
it livens up the
class a little bit,
and this book is especially
good for sound demos.
So I encourage you
at least to get
the online edition
of that textbook.
So also on the course
website is the syllabus
for what the audition
lectures will cover,
and I just put a couple
here to give you a flavor.
In the first lecture
on October 28th,
we'll talk about the physical
characteristics of sound
and what happens
to that sound when
it strikes your
external, and then
your middle, and inner ears.
And associated with each lecture
is an original research article
that, in this case,
is Hofman, et al.,
and the title is "Relearning
Sound Localization
with New Ears."
And so, in a nutshell, what
they did in that research report
was they took little
pieces of clay,
and they inserted them into
their external ears or pinna,
and therefore distorted
quite a lot your pinnae.
They couldn't do
what van Gogh did,
which was cut off the
pinna, but they certainly
distorted their pinnaes
quite a lot on both sides.
And then they tested,
using themselves
as subjects and
other volunteers,
how good their ability
to localize sound was.
And especially in terms of when
the sound varied in elevation,
they found that there
were huge differences,
that they couldn't localize
sounds that were straight ahead
versus sounds that were
coming from above themselves
with these distortions.
But what was funny
and what harks back
to the title of the
article is that when
they had the volunteers go out
and live their normal lives
with these pinna distortions
in for a few weeks,
then they came back into the
lab and tested them again,
they found that they could now
localize sounds in elevation
with these new ears.
They relearned how
to localize sound.
So this is a nice demonstration
of learning or plasticity,
at least in
psychophysical responses.
And it also emphasizes
the function
of your external ear, which
helps you localize sounds
in space.
In the second lecture, we'll
be talking about the receptor
cells for hearing, which are
called hair cells because they
have these little
appendages at their top
that looked to the early
neuroanatomists like hairs.
And of course, sound
is a mechanical energy
that moves the fluid in which
these hair cells are immersed
and moves these little
hairs or appendages
at the top of the
cell, and that's
how the cell can
respond then to sound.
And so hair cells are the
very important receptor cells
for hearing, which are, of
course, the analogs of the rods
and cones in the visual system.
And the research
report associated
with our talk about
hair cells will
be how a special protein
called prestin is required
for electromotility, which
is a function of outer hair
cells, one of the two
types of hair cells,
which allows them to actually
move and flux and change
their membrane links
when they sense
these mechanical disturbances
by their stereocilia.
So it's a pretty
interesting paper
in what we call a
knockout animal.
So the prestin is
genetically knocked out
in this particular animal,
and the sense of hearing
is then tested again in
these knockout animals.
So we have a whole
bunch of lectures.
I haven't indicated all them.
They're on the course website.
Toward the end of the semester,
we'll have, as Peter indicated,
a written assignment
for audition.
So I haven't actually
thought it up yet,
but let me just
give you an example.
Last year and this year,
we'll be talking a lot
about neural prostheses
for audition.
And the most famous neural
prosthesis for audition,
of course, is the
cochlear implant,
which I'll talk a
little bit about later,
and it works quite well.
There's also a neural
prosthesis that
goes into the
auditory brainstem.
It's called the auditory
brainstem implant,
and it's used in
some other types
of individuals who are deaf.
And it doesn't work anywhere
near as well as the cochlear
implant.
It's sometimes called a
lip reading assist device
because people who have
the brainstem implant
usually can't understand
speech over the telephone.
They need to be facing you
and looking at your lips
as you're speaking.
They need additional cues.
And so there'll be
a lot of discussion
this term about the
differences between these two
types of the implant,
where they're
put in the auditory
pathway, and why
one works much better
than the other.
And that was the
written assignment
for last year, which was a
discussion of why the cochlear
implant works a lot better than
the auditory brainstem implant.
So I'll have something
along those lines that
uses the material
from our course
that you can take to
answer a question.
OK.
Let me just go through in
a half a dozen slides or so
what I consider to
be the high points
of the auditory
part of the course.
About the first third of the
auditory part of the course
will be a discussion of
the auditory periphery.
And the periphery
is usually divided
into these three basic
divisions, the external ear,
which most of us think about as
the ear, the pinna and the ear
canal, which leads to
the tympanic membrane
here in yellow, or eardrum.
And at that point
begins the middle ear.
The middle ear is
an air-filled space.
If you've been on a
recent plane flight
and your ears are a
little bit stuffed up,
it can be very uncomfortable,
especially when
the plane is coming
down in altitude.
And your eardrum bulges
because the eardrum is just
a very thin layer of skin,
and it can bulge very easily.
But it's painful
when the eardrum
bulges when the
change in pressure
happens as you're
descending in a plane.
In the air-filled
space of the middle ear
are three small bones,
the malleus, the incus,
and the stapes.
If you remember from high school
biology, the hammer, the anvil,
and the stirrup.
The stirrup looks like what
a cowboy has on his saddle
that he puts the
cowboy boots through.
It's a very, very small bone.
In fact, it's the
smallest bone in the body.
These bones are very
small because they
have to vibrate in
response to sound,
and so they can't
be big and massive.
Massive things don't
vibrate very well.
And so the stapes is sometimes
encompassed by bony growths
around it and prevented
from vibration
in a disease called
otosclerosis.
And so at my hospital,
the Massachusetts Eye
and Ear Infirmary,
they do an operation
to cure that type of deafness
called the stapedectomy.
So what's an -ectomy?
You medical types,
what does that mean?
AUDIENCE: Removal.
PROFESSOR: It means
removal, right.
So they take the stapes out.
And that's because if
they just loosen it up,
the bone regrows and re-adheres
the stapes from vibration.
So they replace the
stapes, the natural stapes,
with a stapes prosthesis, either
a little piston or a tube,
that they hook on with
a wire to the incus,
and they put into the so-called
foot plate area or oval
window of the cochlea, which
is the next structure I'll
talk about.
And that very nicely restores
the sense of hearing.
In fact, when I was a postdoc
fellow at Mass Eye and Ear,
I could go watch the surgeries,
and I watched a stapedectomy.
And the patient was
anesthetized, but not
so much that she was really out.
She was more sedated.
And at the end of the
operation, the surgeon
was adjusting the
artificial prosthesis,
and the surgeon said,
well, can you hear me?
And the patient didn't respond.
So he moved it around a little
bit or adjusted the wire,
I don't know which.
He says, can you hear me now?
And there was no response
from the patient.
And he did a little more
manipulation and adjustment.
And he finally said,
can you hear me?
And the patient said, why
are you yelling at me?
I can hear you just fine.
So usually at the
end of the operation,
the patient has
become more light.
The anesthesiologist
turns off the anesthesia.
And they adjust the stapes
prosthesis so it works well.
So that type of operation
is fairly common
and very successful to
restore the so-called types
of conductive hearing loss.
These bones conduct the acoustic
sensation into the cochlea.
Now, in the cochlea-- this
is the structure here.
The "cochlea" is the
word for the inner ear.
It comes from the Greek word
"kokhlias," which means snail,
and it is certainly a
snail shell-shaped capsule.
The cochlea looks like
a coiled snail shell.
And inside it are
the receptor cells
for hearing, the hair
cells and the dendrites
of the auditory nerve fibers.
OK?
And the cochlea is a
bony-filled capsule
filled with fluid and
membranes and cells inside.
And this anatomy is
a little bit complex,
so I brought in a model here
of the auditory periphery.
So we have the external
ear, the long ear canal
here, the eardrum.
It's kind of slanted here.
And this part here
that I'll lift out here
is the cochlea or the inner ear,
the snail shell-shaped area.
And leading from it is the
yellow-colored, in this case,
auditory nerve, which sends
messages from the cochlea
into the brain.
And these funny, loop-shaped
structures that I'm grasping
are the semicircular
canals, which
mediate the sense of balance
or angular acceleration.
When you rotate your head,
those hair cells in there
are sensitive to
those rotations.
OK.
So I'll pass this model around.
You can take a
closer look at it.
And in our hospital,
the surgeons practice
on real, live specimens like
that from postmortem material
because in otologic
surgery there's
a lot of drilling to access,
for example, the middle ear
or the inner ear.
And there's a lot of
important structures
that you don't want to run
into with your drill bit,
like the jugular bulb
is that red thing there.
The facial nerve goes right
through the middle ear.
And so the surgeons need to know
their way around the middle ear
so that they can avoid
important structures
and go to the right structure
that they intend to operate on.
OK.
So you heard Dr. Schiller
talk about electrophysiology
and recordings from
individual neurons.
And a lot of what we know
about how the inner ear works
comes from such
types of experiments.
And this is an experiment
at the top here
that gives the responses in
the form of action potentials.
Each one of these blips is
a little action potential,
or impulse, or response from
one single auditory nerve
fiber recorded in the
auditory nerve of a cat, which
is the very common model
for auditory neuroscience,
or at least it
was in years past.
So this response area is a
mapping of sound frequency.
So this axis is tone frequency.
And the frequency
of a sound wave form
is simply how many times
it repeats back and forth
per second.
Frequencies that are
common in human hearing
are, for example, 1,000 hertz.
This is a graph of kilohertz,
tone frequency in kilohertz.
And the upper limit
of human hearing
is approximately 20 kilohertz.
The lower limit of human hearing
is down around 50 or 100 hertz.
In terms of smaller
animals like the cat,
they're shifted up in frequency
of perhaps an octave, maybe
a doubling of the frequencies
that they're most sensitive to.
This auditory nerve
fiber responded
to a variety of frequencies,
except at the very lowest
sound level.
The y-axis is a
graph of sound level.
This is very low
level or soft sound,
this would be a
medium sound, and this
would be a very
high level sound.
At the lowest levels of sound,
the auditory nerve fiber
only gave a response
to frequencies
around 10 kilohertz, or
10,000 cycles per second.
There are some spontaneous
firings from the nerve fiber,
and those can happen even if
there's no sound presentation.
These neurons can be
spontaneously active.
If you outline
this response area,
you can see that it's
very sharply tuned
to sound frequency.
It only responds
around 10 kilohertz.
And this exquisitely sharp
tuning of the auditory nerve
is the way, perhaps, that the
auditory nerve sends messages
to the brain that there is only
10 kilohertz that the ears are
hearing and not 9 kilohertz
and not 11 kilohertz.
OK?
If you increase the sound
level to higher levels,
this auditory nerve
fiber, like others,
responds to a wide variety
of sound frequencies,
but it has a very sharp cut
off at the high frequency edge.
Maybe at 11 kilohertz,
it responds,
but 11.1 kilohertz
there's no response.
So the tuning becomes
broader, but there's still
a really nice, sharp,
high-frequency cut off.
So what good is this for?
Well, the ear is very good at
resolving frequency, saying
there's 10 kilohertz
but not 9 kilohertz.
And that's very important
for identification of sounds.
For example, how do we know, if
we're talking on the telephone
or not seeing the subject
who's talking to us,
that it's a female
speaker or a male speaker
or an infant speaker?
Well, male speakers
have lower frequencies
in their speech sounds.
And so right away, if we
hear a lot of low frequencies
in the speech sounds,
we assume we're
talking to a male speaker.
And that's, of course, a very
important identification.
How do we know we're
hearing the vowel A and not
the vowel E, ah or eh?
Because of the different
frequencies in the speech
sounds for those two vowels.
So frequency coding is
a very important subject
in the auditory pathway
for identification
and distinguishing
different types of sounds.
And one way we know what
frequencies we're listening to
is if the auditory
nerve fiber's tuned
to a particular
frequency [INAUDIBLE]
responding and not the others.
Now, some very
elegant studies have
been done to look at
the mapping of frequency
along the spiral of the cochlea.
And what those show
is that way down
at the base of the cochlea,
the very highest frequencies
are sensed by the hair cells
and the auditory nerve fibers
there.
And as you go more
and more apically,
you arrive at first middle,
and then lower frequencies.
So there's a very
nice, orderly mapping
of frequency along the
receptor epithelium,
or along the cochlea in
the sense of hearing.
And so, obviously,
the hearing organ
is set up to distinguish
frequencies and identify
sounds.
OK.
So that's not the only code for
sound frequency that we have.
We'll talk extensively
about another code
that uses a time-coding sense.
And this comes from the way
that auditory nerve fibers
so-called phase lock to
the sound's waveform.
Here's a sound stimulus, and
here's auditory firing, first
with no stimulus.
It's a fairly random pattern.
And here is with a
stimulus turned on,
and you can see that the spikes
line up during a certain phase
or part of the
stimulus waveform.
And that's not that
impressive until you
look at the time scale here.
As I said before, sounds that
are important in human hearing
are as high in frequency
as 1 kilohertz.
So if this is going back and
forth 1,000 times per second,
then the scale bar here for one
period would be 1 millisecond.
And so the auditory nerve is
keeping track and firing only
on a certain or preferential
phase of the stimulus waveform
with the capability
of milliseconds.
OK?
And this is a much better
phase-locking pattern
than you get in other senses.
For example, in
the visual system,
when you flash the light on
and off just even 100 flashes
per second, everything
sort of blears out,
and you sort of don't
have any phase locking
the way you do in the
auditory nerves firing.
So this is a very nice coding
for sound frequency that
is sort of a
secondary way to code.
This is a very important
coding for musical sounds.
Musical sounds, for
example, like an octave,
1 kilohertz and 2 kilohertz,
a doubling of sound frequency,
have very similar patterns
in their temporal responses
to those two frequencies
that probably
makes an octave a very beautiful
musical interval to listen to.
And it appears in music of many
different types of cultures.
So one of the
demonstrations that I'll
play for you is
an A for 40 hertz
and an octave above that,
880 hertz, and you'll
hear how beautiful the
two sound together.
And then I'll mistune
them, which is easy for me
to do because I'm an
amateur violinist,
and I'll be doing
this on a violin.
And it's pretty easy to
have a mistuned octave,
and it sounds so awful
and very dissonant
when you listen to it.
And one of the reasons for
that, the reason for that,
is the difference
in phase locking
for the two dissonant sounds
versus the two consonant
sounds.
OK.
So we will talk
about what happens
when you have problems
with your hearing.
One of the main
problems with hearing
that causes loss,
complete loss of hearing,
is when the receptor
cells are attacked
by various types of
insults, diseases, drugs,
the aging process,
stimulation, or listening
to very high-level sounds.
These can all kill
the hair cells.
And in the mammalian cochlea,
once the hair cells are lost
they never grow back.
And there's very active
interest in trying
to get hair cells to
regenerate by using
stem cells or various
growth factors,
but so far that
can't be achieved.
Luckily, in the
auditory periphery,
even if you lose the
hair cells, which
is the major cause
of deafness, you
retain your auditory
nerve fibers.
So these blue structures here
are the auditory nerve fibers
coming from the hair cells.
And even if the hair
cells are killed
by these various insults,
the auditory nerve fibers,
or at least many
of them, remain.
So you heard Dr. Schiller talk
about electrical stimulation.
You can put an electrical
stimulating electrode
in the inner ear and stimulate
those remaining auditory nerve
fibers to fire impulses
that are sent to the brain.
And if you hook that
system up right,
you have a so-called
cochlear implant.
The cochlear implant has a
microphone that detects sound.
It has a processor that converts
that sound into various pulses
of electrical stimulating
current, which
can be applied to a
system of electrodes
that is inserted
into the cochlea.
The cochlea is a
beautiful bony capsule.
You can snake this electrode in.
It doesn't move away.
You can glue it in place.
You can lead the electrode
out to the processor that
activates it when the
subject hears a sound that's
detected by the microphone.
And this cochlear implant
is the most successful
neural prosthesis
that's been developed.
It's implanted all the time
at Mass Eye and Ear Infirmary.
It's paid for by insurance.
These days, insurance pays
for a cochlear implant
in your left cochlea
if you're deaf,
and it will also pay for
another cochlear implant
in your right cochlea
if you're deaf.
So the metric for how
successful this is,
is whether the subject who's
using the cochlear implant
can understand speech.
And so you can have
various tests of speech.
A speaker can give a sentence,
and the person can respond.
The speaker can give
various simple words,
and the cochlear implant
user can respond.
You can test these individuals
in a very straightforward
manner.
And we will have a demonstration
by a cochlear implant user.
I have an undergraduate
demonstrator who's here at MIT.
And she'll come in and
she'll describe and show you
her cochlear implant, and
you can ask her questions.
And there, I guarantee you with
this particular demonstration
that I have in mind,
that she won't always
understand your questions.
I have had really great
cochlear implant users
who are superstars, that
understand every word.
But the more norm is they
understand much of what you say
but not everything.
And this particular room is
a little bit challenging.
There's some noise
in the background.
It's not one-on-one,
so the implant user
won't know exactly
who's speaking at once.
And in this case, the person
just has one ear implanted,
so her ability to localize
sounds is compromised.
And she won't know who's asking
the question until she sort
of zeroes in a little bit on it.
So you'll see the cochlear
implant is not perfect,
but it's pretty
good in its metric
for speech comprehension.
OK.
Now, I said this particular
cochlear implant user only
has one implant in one ear.
To really be good
at localizing sound,
we need to have
two ears, and there
are the so-called binaural
cues for sound localization.
Here's a subject listening
to a sound source.
The sound source is
emitting sound here,
and it gets to the
subject's left ear first.
And a short time later, it gets
to the subject's right ear.
And that's one of the cues for
binaural localization of sound,
which is interaural
time difference.
The velocity of sound in air
is 342 meters per second.
And depending on how
big your head is,
you can calculate the
Interaural Time Difference.
And of course,
that ITD is maximal
if the sound source is
located off to one side,
and it's exactly zero
if the sound source
is located straight ahead.
OK?
So that is a cue for
localization of sounds.
We'll listen to sounds that
differ in interaural time
difference.
We can play these through
headphones for you.
And we'll have some
demonstrations of that.
The other binaural cue
for sound localization
is the interaural
level difference.
Here is the same sound
source, same subject.
This ear will experience a
slightly higher sound level
than the other ear because
sound can't perfectly
bend around the head.
The head creates a sound shadow.
And this is especially important
for high frequencies of sound,
like above 3 kilohertz.
So that is a second binaural
cue for sound localization.
We'll listen to those cues.
And we'll talk a lot about
the brainstem processing
of those binaural cues
for sound localization.
If you compare the visual
and the auditory pathways--
this is a block diagram
of the auditory pathway,
and there are a lot
of brainstem nuclei.
We have the cochlear nucleus,
the superior olivary complex,
and the inferior colliculus.
And these latter two get input
from the two ears on the two
sides, and they
probably do the bulk
of the neural processing
for sound localization.
You don't have to do that
so much in the visual system
because the visual
system, in a sense,
has a mapping of external
space already on the retina.
But remember, the inner
ears map sound frequency.
And so the inner ears
themselves don't know
or don't have a
good cue for where
the sound is localized in space.
Instead, you need input
from the two sides,
and you need a lot
of neural processing
to help you determine
where that sound source is
coming from in space.
OK.
So we'll talk about
the neural processing
of those binaural cues.
We'll talk toward
the end of the course
about the various
auditory cortical fields.
These are the cortical fields
in the side of the cat's brain.
So this is the
front of the brain.
This is looking at the
left side of the brain.
This is the rear of the brain
where the occipital lobes are,
where V1 is.
And on the side or
temporal cortex,
you have the auditory
fields, including
A1 or primary auditory cortex.
And we'll talk, at least
touch upon a little bit,
toward the end of the course
the human auditory-- primary
auditory cortical field is right
here on the superior surface
of the superior temporal gyrus.
And just near it, it could be
called an auditory association
area, is an area
called Wernicke's area
that's very important in
processing of language.
And of course,
connected with that
is the Broca's area, which
is another important language
center, in the dominant
hemisphere at least, of humans.
So we'll touch upon that at
the very end of the course.
And we'll also have a special
topic called bat echolocation,
how bats use their auditory
sense to navigate around
the world at night even
without their vision.
And finally, at the very last
class period before the review
sessions, we'll all go over
for a tour of the research lab
where I work at the
Massachusetts Eye and Ear
Infirmary.
So it's across the Longfellow
Bridge right at the end
there where the arrow is.
And we'll have some
demonstrations there.
I think last year we
had a demonstration
on single-unit recording
from an awake animal that's
listening to sound.
We had measurements from humans
of the so-called otoacoustic
emissions.
These are sounds
that can be detected
in the ear canal with a
very sensitive microphone.
They're used in
tests of hearing.
And I also think
we had a discussion
of imaging of the
auditory system.
And of course, if you've ever
listened to an MRI machine,
it's sort of described
sometimes as being
as loud as being inside
a washing machine.
And it's very
challenging for people
that image subjects
who are listening
to especially very
low-level sounds
when there's all this background
noise coming from the imaging
machine.
So there's some
special things that
are done to minimize
the noise coming
from the imager in
auditory studies.